good morning Hank it's Monday you just
got said hello to buy hundreds of
nerdfighters but Hank that was yesterday
and today's video isn't about yesterday
it's about today so what happened today
I got up I brushed my teeth I took a
shower a change clothes I can't show you
that because I worry that the blinding
beauty of my naked body might result in
nerdfighters getting retinal damage but
trust me it was awesome then I went
downstairs in a minute but david say hi
David hi Damon and then we went to the
airport the airport everybody got an
aligned to find out if we had metal in
our pockets and I tried to videotape
that line of people waiting to find out
if they had metal in their pockets but
then the government got mad at me for
trying to videotape that because
apparently it's illegal once I found out
that I didn't have any metal in my
pockets I wouldn't got a sandwich which
was not as delicious as its price
indicated it would be then I had to sit
against the great speckled wall of the
airport in order to plug in my computer
and I tried to go to my quiet place but
then I remembered that I had to tell you
something oh so hey my Dutch publisher
Lemna Scott they're gonna be
re-releasing Looking for Alaska or as it
is known in Dutch head grote machine and
they have an awesome idea which is that
they want you to design cover ideas for
Looking for Alaska and then if they like
your idea enough your cover could be in
the Netherlands and now back to your
regularly scheduled voiceover so we got
onto the airplane I like airplanes
except when they go into the sky then
they scare the crap out of me the
airplane took us to a different airport
although you couldn't tell it was
different from the wall color then we
drove into San Francisco and then we
checked into our hotel the angel lady at
our hotel by the way has hair in exactly
the right place and then I got into my
hotel room and took out my phone and
looked at pictures of Henry because he
is a cute little bugger and I'm missing
like crazy cakes and then it was now
it's actually still now never stops
being now on this Sarah and Henry and
I'm tired and I miss having time to
write but in a couple hours I get to go
meet hundreds of people who've read the
book that David and I wrote together and
that makes me feel like the luckiest guy
in the world so Hank I just want to say
thanks to the nerdfighters for making my
day possible for making this tour such a
blast oh and Hank you may remember that
the nerdfighters with the HP Alliance
raised so much money to help Haiti heal
that we filled four planes with medicine
and
that's desperately needed well I think
the fourth and final plane leaves for
Haiti on Thursday and you know what
Partners in Health is calling it the SS
dftba how awesome is that
Hank I'll see you on Wednesday
trying to figure out if there is in fact
a tune to summer of gay I kind of would
love to actually sing one of these songs
are being able to but I just don't know
that I have the tiny Cooper inmate oh
you have the tiny prepare today well I
mean yeah
I like tyrunt fagina with finer